this is black hole consciousness
your pupil is the absolute
victimization is the highest illusion
you are the programmer of your Portal's
experience
the whole thing is encoded in the body
the aperture contracts with trauma and
expands with catharsis
everyone is a computer scientist
tinkering innovating testing the limits
of open space
infinite interpenetrative portals
like an ant colony or beehive
harvesting the nectar of perceptual
morphisms
choosing our performance acting our part
all children are of the same family
space Mycelia
whatever you're looking at is you
you're always looking at yourself
characters are made of air sparring
against each other
why we love video games is because it's
air sparring
there's no difference between the
holographic immersion of a video game
and this
you are exploring your portals
programmable limits
you may think your experience points are
collecting external things but you've
been down that path many times before
the only experience points that matter
in the dojo of black hole Consciousness
are perceptual morphisms
how viscerally did you expand your
aperture and serve others to do the same
once you become the whole infinite ant
colony you are free
nothing is left but basic needs and
prosperous decentralized Earth
cracking jokes laughing and helping open
space undergo all kinds of expansion to
head back home
this open space belongs to nothing
nobody
you forever
void is a nebula sparring itself
the pupils are its portals
perception is a programmable vacuity
there are infinite ways to contract and
expand apertures in dance
if you reclaim the author your
victimization incinerates
now we know why the number one game
that's played is
I'm not it